l'enregistrement a été authentifié par
la cia
oussama ben laden s'est à nouveau
manifesté hier soir une déclaration où
le chef d'al-qaïda a disculpé zacarias
moussaoui
il déclare que le français est condamné
à perpétuité aux états unis n'est en
rien lié aux attentats du 11 septembre
bertrand boyer cette fois ci c'est sous
forme d'une lettre sonore diffusé sur
internet qu'oussama ben laden reprend la
parole ben laden y apparaît en photo et
début de son intervention en précisant
le rôle de celui qu'il nomme l'honorable
frères acariès moussaoui ce français
condamné à perpétuité aux états unis
pour complicité dans les attentats du 11
septembre
la vérité c'est qu'il n'a aucun lien
avec les événements du 11 septembre et
je suis sûr de ce que je dis puisque je
suis personnellement responsable de
l'attribution des rôles aux 19 frère
pour mener cette mission
les aveux selon lesquelles il était
chargé de participer à ces conquêtes
sont nuls et non avenus hung c'est la
première fois que ben laden reconnaît
explicitement son rôle dans
l'organisation du 11 septembre
pour les analystes du risque terroriste
ce document authentifié par les services
de renseignement américains vise à le
repositionner dans une mouvance où
s'impose désormais d'autres leaders
je pense que tout ça est pour remuer le
couteau dans la plaie des américains
après un procès qui a lui-même réactiver
toutes les souffrances créé douleur etc
donc je pense qu'il rentre dans une
brèche et que c'est une façon de dire
encore aux états unis au gouvernement
bush en fait qu' il est toujours là et
qu'il faudrait contenir un ferme à
l'amérique plus tard dans
l'enregistrement ben laden affirme que
les prisonniers de guantanamo n'ont rien
à voir avec le 11 septembre et que bon
nombre d'entre eux n'ont aucun lien avec
al qaïda
pour ce spécialiste du monde musulman la
multiplication de ces interventions
visent un double objectif
il met en cause de l'intérieur la
justice occidentale et il participe à la
remise en doute à la démolition du
système
intellectuel du système juridique des
démocraties occidentales et cela ils le
font bien sûr pour essayer de recruter
des soutiens dans la population au moyen
orient
l'intervention de ben laden ne changera
en rien le destin de zacarias moussaoui
désormais incarcéré dans cette prison de
haute sécurité dont il ne sortira
probablement jamais et justement ça